Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Rohan Oza,
the branding guru behind
some of the world's
most successful consumer
products joins the Tank.
Robert knows technology
to build stuff.
I know how to build brands.
Together, it's a dynamic duo.
Always be closing!
I love that!
‐Did you see that?
‐Wow!
‐That's cool.
‐This is the solution.
Kyle, that is the winner!
Barbara's right.
Your packaging's horrible!
I know that.
What do you want, Mark?
What do you want?
Got to be kidding me.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a redesign
of a common party accessory.
♪♪
Hello. My name is Kyle Donovan,
and I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
And I'm here seeking $100,000
for 5% of my company, iFork.
Now, Sharks, let me
ask you a question.
Have you ever been to backyard
barbecue, a birthday party,
or a picnic and you went
and picked up
a cool, delicious cup
of lemonade.
And then you went
and grabbed your plate.
And you've filled
it up with food.
Now you have to do what I call
the "two‐hand shuffle".
To eat any food,
you have to find some place
to put down your drink.
And the next thing you know,
here come Aunt Betsy,
and she wants a hug.
And now your fork done
fell on the floor in the dirt.
‐[ Sighs ]
‐[ Laughs ]
But I believe there's a way
we can eat, drink, and be merry.
It's an all‐in‐one, innovative,
interlocking system
designed to make
your life easier.
So now if you need a free hand
[scoffs] don't even
worry about it.
Gently squeeze your iCup
and slide it on in
till it locks in place.
‐Oh, wow, that's cool.
‐Did you see that?
‐Whoo!
‐Wow!
‐That's cool.
‐Of course,
you're going to want to eat
some of that delicious food.
All you got to do is slide out
your iFork and dig right in.
And when you're done, it nestles
right back into place.
The iFork product line
is a massive improvement
over traditional flatware.
The reason being is its
innovative notch right here.
That's designed to keep the part
that goes into your mouth
from ever touching
dirty surfaces.
Would you eat your food
directly from a surface?
Of course not!
That's nasty.
So why would you eat from a for
that's been lying on one?
‐Huh?
‐Now, you have a free hand
to do the latest thing.
‐♪ Well, well, well ♪
And be the life of the party.
‐Yeah!
‐♪ I got my iCup ♪
♪ My iPlate ♪
♪ My hand's free,
you feel great ♪
♪ I'm about to eat,
I can't wait ♪
♪ I got my drink,
I slid it in ♪
♪ I got my iCup,
my iPlate ♪
[ Music ends ]
‐And with that ‐‐
‐Outstanding!
‐Wow!
‐Yeah!
‐Great!
‐Thank you.
I love the "iJingle".
I would love to pass
y'all some samples
and answer any questions
that you might have.
‐Please!
‐Let's see it.
♪ The iCup, the iPlate ♪
♪ Da ♪
It's nice to hear music
for a change, right?
Yeah.
‐What are we drinking here?
‐That's lemonade.
This has got
a little kick for you.
Thank you.
How do I...
put it back in?
Just squeeze it.
And utensils,
you gently lift them.
Slide those out,
slide those back in.
Thank you.
This is about a three‐minute
learning curve.
But once you get it, you got it.
‐Do you have a patent on this?
‐I'm glad you mentioned that.
I do have patents.
If you notice right here‐‐
I see, like, 16 of them.
Greiner: Do you have a utility
patent, or is it just design?
I have utility patents pending.
And I have quite a few
design patents.
And I did that mainly because
I was blessed enough
to get a 500‐store test
for Wal‐Mart.
So before the utility patents
were approved,
I was, like, you know what,
let me double back
and build a little patent wall
around this
to protect the proprietary.
Tell us a little bit
about yourself.
Well, my background
is quite interesting.
I actually grew up
without my mother and father
in my life
in the projects of Brooklyn.
And I guess I was
an entrepreneur all my life
because early on,
me and my cousin literally
used to go into garbage cans
in the streets of Brooklyn
and collect bottles.
And that's how we made
money for the summer.
And I ended up getting
my first full‐time job at 15.
I worked in a photo lab.
And at 19, I opened up
my own photography studio.
‐Good for you. Wow.
‐Wow.
So I actually had some
pretty big accounts ‐‐
EMI‐Capital Records, Dow Jones,
New York Times.
And then I decided to start
a business magazine
towards urban professionals.
And at 26 years old,
I launched what became
the second‐largest
urban business magazine
in the country.
‐You've got to be kidding.
‐What was it called? Which one?
‐NV, New Vision in Business.
‐NV? Yeah.
‐I'm proud to say
one of your colleagues,
Daymond,
was actually on the third‐ever
cover of it.
‐Is it still active?
‐It is still active.
I have someone now running it
while I focus on this full time.
This is all I do, eat, breathe,
and sleep. That's it.
But how did you get from
a magazine business
to this kind of a business?
It always bothered me
when I was at restaurants
and they would take my fork
out of my appetizer
and lay it on my table.
I was, like,
"This is disgusting".
Like, "I'm going to need
a new fork.
This is really bothering me".
You've had the Wal‐mart story.
I got to hear about that.
Yes. Thank you.
You have a big order
from Wal‐mart.
It was for 500 stores.
18,000 units.
This is before
the cup and plate.
Wal‐mart actually has not
seen the cup and plate yet.
You're some of the first
to see it.
‐They haven't?
‐They have not.
So it's just the iFork
they bought into.
‐So what did they buy into?
‐They just saw the iFork.
Actually, the side
kicks right here,
that was actually
in 500 stores.
‐Dollar amount.
‐$26,000.
So I'm going to guess
what Wal‐mart didn't reorder.
They told me I hadn't
built brand up enough
to warrant shelf space.
They didn't want
to take the risk.
And how did it sell in Wal‐mart?
What was your turn?
Most of them sold out
in, like, two weeks.
It sold well.
The fork or the knife that
doesn't rest on the table,
I don't think is a problem
that needs to be solved.
What I think is this problem
that you are solving
is this one here.
The one where you actually
want to put a drink and eat.
This is the solution.
‐Kyle, that is the winner!
‐Yeah, I hear you.
So my question is,
what's the economics
on this thing?
And have you sold
any of these things yet?
I just got my first container.
In addition‐‐
This is the magic.
‐Yes, I agree.
‐It's buying it as a set.
And what is the price
of that?
Ideally, when I get to retail,
I want them to retail
for $15.99.
Kyle, I'm going to guess
that a standard
comparative plastic set
is going to be around $10.
And you're at $15.99.
And it's
a better mouse trap.
No, I agree.
But it's definitely more ‐‐
it's 50% more.
The challenge is, you have
to demonstrate it
for people to see the value
and really have it register.
‐Right.
‐That's another challenge.
Right, that's the hard part
right there.
Right.
Kyle, I'd like to make you
an offer, if I may, okay?
Bam!
I'll give you
the $100,000.
I do want 20% because
it's a very young business.
But the contingency I have is
that you redesign the plate
so you can hold
a standard cup.
I would guess 70%
of the cups out there
are the same size
and shape.
I know the drinking cup
always has a ridge.
I don't know if a wine cup
has a ridge.
If so,
that would be phenomenal.
Wine cup that attaches
to this.
Ohh.
But I think your price
is way too high
and the packaging sucks.
You'd have to really
redesign the package.
It's, like, it's out
of the 1950's.
But just a simple plate
that holds a cup.
If you do that, I'm very happy
to give you the money.
I'm very happy
to help you market it,
slam it into the stores,
whatever you need.
You know, I think you
cut yourself out of a very,
very large market.
You know, I like to use
Solo cups as a case study.
Solo was the one
I was thinking.
As a case study, they're doing
$1.6 billion a year in cups.
So if you just make it the plate
to fit every other cup,
you could lose that potential.
Could you design a plate
to hold a Solo cup?
No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
You got it wrong, Kyle.
You saw the problem
that $1.6 billion
worth of revenue
already has.
You don't lose the opportunity.
You get the ball rolling.
So if this plate ‐‐
and I've got
my red Solo cup, and I pop it
in there, I'm going, "Wow!"
I mean, Barbara's idea's
a really good idea
because then you can
take any cup out there,
people don't have to buy
yours or keep yours...
‐Yes!
‐...or if they break yours,
replace it.
You're in the plate
business, period.
They can take any Solo cup
and put it in.
Barbara's right.
Your packaging's horrible!
No, I agree.
Your packaging
for your iFork sucks.
‐Right?
‐I concur.
Your packaging
for your kits sucks.
The fact that you
make up buy this
when people already have cups
in their closet sucks.
The fact that you've got this
where I have to have
these forks sucks.
But, but ‐‐
But the lemon
cake is great.
But, but, but,
but, but ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
That does not suck.
Herjavec: I would just
cut him off now and move on.
But that's okay.
That's okay 'cause you're
this close.
‐To not sucking.
‐Right? You're this close.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
I thank you very much, Mark.
Really appreciate it.
Listen,
this is a good product.
It's clever. My concern here
is I think that the marketing
of this is going to be
a little tricky.
I think it's going to be
challenging to get
the consumer to understand
what it is
and sell it at retail.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
All right, thank you
very much, Lori.
Oza:
Barbara's quite brilliant.
I think you should have
seen that potential
where one second,
I'm going to design this
for the multi‐billion
dollar cup market.
I'm out.
All right,
thank you very much.
Herjavec:
Yeah, Kyle, listen.
You have every excuse
to have an excuse.
You grew up in a bad
neighborhood,
you have to hustle
your whole life.
If anybody had the right to
come out here and complain,
it was you,
and you never did that.
Full respect to you
for that.
Thank you for that.
I mean, forget the excuses
and make the most of your life.
I'd love to be
in business with you
because you're
definitely a winner.
But I'm going to bow out
'cause I think Barbara's
a great partner
and that's a great offer.
I'm out.
Thank you, I greatly
appreciate that.
Cuban: What are you
going to do, Kyle?
Yeah.
Because not a lot
of choices right now.
I understand. Barbara,
I definitely greatly
appreciate ‐‐
appreciate the offer.
Is there any way we can
bring the equity down a bit?
Kyle, based on the sales
that you have,
there's really no proven
traction on the sales yet.
It's a start.
Long way from the finish line.
It's on the table there,
Kyle.
Would you like to do
some business with me?
I mean, I would, Barbara.
Can we do the $100,000
for 15%?
♪♪
‐You got it. Got a deal.
‐Done!
‐Ah!
‐Wow!
‐Good job, Barbara.
‐Good job.
‐Great job!
‐Ahh!
Ta‐da!
Come to me, here.
I'm in spikes.
‐Killing the game.
‐Thank you so much.
Come here.
‐Congratulations.
‐Great job.
‐Congrats, Kyle.
‐Good job.
‐Very clever.
‐Good one, Barbara.
Being a one‐man show
for so long,
it took blood, sweat, and tears.
So to have someone like
Barbara as part of this
is nothing short of amazing.
[ Voice breaking ]
I'm very happy, very happy.
It was a long road.
I can't even believe I'm crying.
[ Sighs ]
Like, anyone watching out there,
if you feel the odds
are stacked against you,
maybe you don't have
your mother in your life
or your father in your life,
your parents in your life.
You know, don't give up.
Keep going.
You know, one day,
this could happen to you.
Dreams can come true.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is an eco‐friendly alternative
to plastic bags.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Kat Nouri,
and I'm the founder
and the creator of Stasher.
And I'm here from
Oakland, California.
And I'm seeking $400,000
for 5% of my company.
Stasher is transforming
the container industry
by providing
a healthier alternative
to plastic bags and containers.
Plastics are filled
with chemicals.
So I invented the first
plastic‐free
silicone pinchlock bag
in the world.
It has all the purity of glass
with the functionality
of plastic.
And Katie and I are
going to show you why
Stasher's becoming
and everyday household staple.
Meal time's always a challenge
for my busy family.
I always forget to take out
what's in the freezer,
like this piece of salmon.
You simply drop it
in a boiling pot of water,
sous‐vide,
microwave, or oven.
Stasher's super compact
and it's super easy to use.
You simply fold over the bag and
you squeeze out the excess air
and you pinch to seal.
And when you're
all done with it,
you can just toss it
in the dishwasher.
So Sharks, what are you going
to stash in your Stasher?
And we have samples for you.
Lovely.
How long before the
salmon is ready?
Right?!
Actually, this is for you.
Oh, this whole Stasher's
for me?
So, yeah. So it's made out
of pure platinum silicone.
So there's no by‐products
in it whatsoever.
Herjavec:
Thank you, Katie.
Greiner: Ooh, are these
those candy mints?
‐Yes.
‐[ Chuckles ]
So, Kat, what are the other
silicone bags on the market?
So there are silicone
bags out there,
but there's nothing that
has a male‐female closure
that can seal by itself,
which means that you could
stick it in the microwave
or in the oven.
And the patents
are all on the seal
and the curve on the inside
so that it doesn't spill and it
opens up like a gape mouth.
Corcoran:
And what do you sell it for?
So you have three
different sizes there.
The prices are $9.99,
$11.99, and $19.99.
Isn't that a lot?
Well, it depends on what
you're paying for, right?
I mean, you're paying
for platinum silicone
that you're going to use
thousands of times,
endlessly, compared
to throw away plastic,
which shouldn't
even be something
that we're doing nowadays.
And I'm not even telling you
about the trillions
of pieces of plastic
in our oceans.
Oza: So what's your story?
How did you get to this point?
Give a little background.
It would be great.
Okay, so the exciting
part about me,
why I'm a good
investment for you
is because I'm a great jockey,
and I'll tell you why.
I've had other companies.
I've done very well.
I'm not just here
to make a buck,
I want to leave this planet
making a difference.
What were your other
businesses?
So I started Modern Twist.
And Modern Twist as
the first company
to make silicone
into a textile.
We have, like,
table runners, place mats.
They're all in, like,
Bloomingdales.
Kat, you must have
tremendous sales
if you're asking
$400,000 for 5%.
On an $8 million
valuation.
That's right.
I do have sales!
Let's hear about
that good news.
‐What sales?
‐Yes, absolutely.
$1.6 million in the 12 months
that we've been in the market.
‐Wow!
‐How does the $1.6 million
break down? Like...
Okay, so this part I really
want Mark or your help
in that. E‐commerce.
So 50% of my sales
is in e‐commerce.
So 30% is in Amazon.
But our own e‐commerce
is only 7%.
Cuban: Kat, what's your
current blended margin?
63%.
63% on $1.6, so,
give or take $970,000
in gross margin dollars.
‐Wow.
‐$1 million to be precise.
Okay, $1 million
in gross margin dollars.
‐Yes.
‐Are you profitable right now?
‐Absolutely.
‐Okay.
Your gross profit
was $1 million...
‐Yes.
‐...on $1.6 million.
What was your net profit
on that million?
‐We had $100,000 last year.
‐Good for you.
‐Great!
‐Good job.
‐Okay, so where did the $900‐‐
‐In the first year, you guys,
and I put all that into ‐‐
because I want to be
$5.2 million this year.
Where does the $900‐‐
And I'll say $5.2, but I'll
do $10 million next year.
You guys, this is
going to be $100 million company
in four years.
I'm telling you that.
[ Laughter ]
Love the confidence,
there, yeah.
What do you say?
You're just along for the ride.
‐You're a beast, Kat.
‐No, I understand.
Kat, you are a beast.
That coming from you is,
like, amazing!
I'll take that!
And I'm done!
She didn't come here to play,
that's for sure.
‐I'm done!
‐Kat,
you are a flurry of energy.
‐Force of nature.
‐It's almost exhausting
to listen to you. I‐‐
Do you know, like, how fun it is
to be in front of the best?
No, no, I ‐‐ I got it.
I don't understand
the advantage of the product.
And the product doesn't
get me excited.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I really appreciate your time.
Corcoran: You're a phenomenal
salesperson, all right?
And if I take you
on face value
and listen to all
of what you said,
I would be jumping out
of my skin to invest in you.
But then when I look
at your product,
the Stasher.
And you're opening comment
was,
"It's a healthy
alternative to plastic".
I see nothing on the packaging
or the claims
to say anything
about health.
And when I have this product
independent of your sales pitch,
I would not buy it
for the price point.
To me, it's another kind of a
bag, okay, at a very high price.
Okay, so you're
a phenomenal salesperson.
If you ever want to sell
real estate, look me up.
[ Chuckles ]
I appreciate it.
But I'm out.
Thank you.
Kat, why haven't you put more
about the environment
and the plastic‐free element?
When I look at the back,
it talks about
the simplicity
of using the product,
but there's nothing
about your health.
I agree. Maybe that's something
that we should definitely
put on the packaging.
If you told me that and you
were one of my buyers,
I'd definitely
put it up there.
Yeah, but that doesn't
work that way.
And this is good feedback
on your side.
This is your vision.
You've got to be able to sell
this away from you.
Wait, wait, wait.
So you're just telling me that
you're looking at this product
and you're not seeing it being
as a healthier alternative
because it doesn't say?
I don't see that.
I don't what it does.
Everything you talked about,
the healthier proposition ‐‐
Okay, Rohan, can I ask you,
you're a brand specialist,
what would you do
that would say that
that is a better option
and it's healthier?
I just want to hear it.
'Cause I ‐‐ for me,
it's very obvious
when you're looking
at fruits and vegetables
coming out of there, I think
that's an intuitive thing
that you're saying,
"Why, what's in this?"
But Kat, it's not.
Well, what this looks
like to me...
Well, why didn't‐‐
...is something
to store vegetables.
The story of cook it,
freeze it, store it ‐‐
one, it's very light,
too hidden, secondly,
the whole fact this is
a healthier vessel for you
to cook, freeze, store
doesn't come through.
So that's a mock thing here
is the product story
is not being conveyed
for the package.
‐At all.
‐So can I put it back on you?
If you were to have
this concept,
how would you do it differently?
We can't do that here.
We can't reinvent it.
Look, Kat, we're
asking you questions
and you're coming back asking
us a question instead, right?
You're not saying, "I get it"
or "I made this choice
because"‐‐
I do get it.
I swear I do get it.
But I'm just saying
that I want to see
where your point of view was.
I don't want to ‐‐
I'm not arguing with you at all.
Kat ‐‐
I mean, there's just not
an easy ‐‐ for me.
‐Lori's got something.
‐Right, right.
Go ahead, Lori.
Kat, to Mark's point,
when you walked in‐‐
Mark, don't go out.
When you walked in
to pitch us ‐‐
Mark, please, nothing!
I just want you to come in
just because I want to prove
it to you that I'll kill it.
Well, then, make me
an offer I can't refuse.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
And it seems that Kat is
targeting Mark for an investment
in her silicone bag company,
Stasher.
Well, then, make me
an offer I can't refuse.
You tell me
what's appetizing for you.
You want me,
make me an offer.
‐Kat.
‐Okay, I'm giving right now ‐‐
Wait, wait. We have something
to share with you over here.
‐I'm doing fi‐‐ Yes?
‐We're both out.
Okay, great.
[ Scoffs ]
Okay, I came in here
asking for $400,000 for 5%.
I'll give you 7% for $400,000.
‐Noooo.
‐I want you!
‐You don't want me that bad.
‐Not that badly, clearly.
‐She wants you so badly.
‐'Cause you will make sure
that I have a line of credit
if I get large accounts.
He will get you into
some of the biggest e‐commerce
out there, so...
I know that.
Oh, you mean 7% is not enough?
Is that what you're saying?
‐No way.
‐Okay.
It's not enough, you mean?
Okay, what do you want, Mark?
What do you want?
‐You want 8%? You want 9%?
‐Inches. He wants to do it ‐‐
I'll do it for $400k plus
a $400k line of credit for 20%.
‐Oh, crud, for real?!
‐But you want him.
‐For reals.
‐Ugh!
For real, Mark?
Okay, 15%.
♪♪
Done.
‐Ohh!
‐All right!
‐Who's the man?!
‐Whoo! Whoo!
‐We are.
‐Oh, my God!
I love it!
We're going to kill it!
‐I'll take it.
‐Thank you, guys.
I'm so excited!
‐Good luck. [ Laughs ]
‐[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
I'm so excited I made
a deal with Mark Cuban.
I think this is going
to be the thing
that's going to move
the needle for us.
And I'm so excited about it,
that Mark Cuban saw our vision.
Hey, Lori,
why'd you guys drop out?
We dropped out because it
was clear she was just...
‐She wanted Mark.
‐...negotiating to Mark.
‐So it was, like...
‐I knew she was smart.
It was just a question
of whether or not
there was a deal there.
We were, like,
"Why would we stay in?"
Lori and I were, like,
"We're in".
‐Yeah.
‐And she was just fast.
We would have been in,
so she kind of lost.
She could've gotten
a better deal. Who knows?
Couldn't get
a better deal than me.
♪♪
Narrator: In season eight,
Harriet and Patrick Mills
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their fun art class
franchise Wine & Design.
Corcoran: Oh, my God!
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
Harriet: When we went on
"Shark Tank" with a nude model,
we had no idea
what was going to happen.
Not only did we shock
the Sharks,
we got a deal with Kevin.
Patrick: We already had
a great business,
but being on "Shark Tank"
has allowed the business
to grow even faster.
In just four months
of "Shark Tank",
we've been able to open eight
more franchise locations,
we have done $3.5 million
in sales.
Today, we're going to reach
a huge milestone.
Our millionth painting
will be created
after six years in business.
And to celebrate, we have
a very special guest
attending our Picasso night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
O'Leary: I've never modeled
before, but you know what ‐‐
you can't mess this up.
I look beautiful.
Did you think I'm really
going to be nude?
This is a family show.
I think Wine & Design
has captured
the experiential element
that people look for
in their lives.
And it's growing like a weed.
People want to paint,
want to be with friends,
and they love to drink wine.
It's a great business.
If you have a smiley face
on the back of your canvas,
you've painted
the millionth painting.
‐Oh, my gosh, it's me!
‐Yes!
Whoo!
Harriet: Being a working mom
and running a thriving business
is hard.
We are 100% all women‐owned
because we want to give
the women a chance
to own their own business, as
well as be able to be flexible
and be a mom, as well.
Our goal is to have
a Wine & Design studio
in every state across America
and hopefully be
in your home town.
One millionth painting,
a million more to come.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a new concept
in the personal wellness
category.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks!
Whoa.
[ Laughter ]
My name is Daniel Turissini.
I'm from Washington, D. C.
And I'm here seeking $75,000
in exchange
for 15% equity stake
in my company, Recharj.
Now, imagine your best employee
tethered to her cellphone 24/7.
She works a challenging job,
unsustainable hours,
gets texts from her boss
at all hours of the night.
She is the classic
high‐value talent
at risk of costly burnout.
Now this is her brain.
And this is her brain on naps.
Power naps are a clear
performance enhancer.
And the fact is that one
in three American adults
said they do doze daily
when and where they can.
Now while companies
don't want to catch
their employees
snoozing at their desk,
a dedicated nap space is
just too cost prohibitive.
So where can weary type A's
go to rest their heads
and a nod off?
Introducing Recharj.
It's the nation's first
and only power nap studio,
designed for busy
businesspeople like you.
Recharj offers respite
from the stress
and strain of
the high‐pressure work day.
So Sharks, I invite you
to close your eyes,
recharge your mind,
recharge your body,
and recharge your wallet
with Recharj.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐And who would like to volunteer
to dive into one of
our power nap cocoons here?
‐I'm in.
‐I'll try it.
‐Come on in!
‐Sure, I'll give it a go.
Herjavec:
How does it work, Daniel?
So customers can either
drop in or book online.
And once they arrive, we escort
them to their power nap cocoon,
which is complete
with a pillow, eye pillow,
blanket, earplugs upon request.
This is superbly comfortable.
Cuban: It feels really good,
actually. Yeah.
It can stretch out.
They are wrapped 360 degrees
in a sound‐dampening
opaque drapery for privacy.
We draw down the lights.
We turn up binaural beach,
which lull the brain
into a transitional state
of consciousness.
It can be a power nap.
Is there a scent?
Do you have a scent as well.
Yes, lavender scent.
So you have sound,
you have scent.
We tickle all the senses.
I like it.
But most importantly,
do you have Wi‐Fi?
[ Laughter ]
We do have Wi‐Fi, but we
collect all phones up front.
‐No phones in our space.
‐You do?
What do you do about slime
on the pillow
or makeup that rubs off?
I don't see a pillowcase.
I wouldn't want to be
on somebody else's stuff.
Absolutely, so we
take cleanliness
at Recharj very seriously.
All hand‐touched materials
are machine washable.
In between each use, each of
our power nap cocoons
are hand inspected, flipped,
rotated, and cleaned.
‐Just to understand ‐‐
‐So you don't really ‐‐
so just so I'm clear
on that.
You don't actually wash
all the covers,
you're spraying them
clean kind of?
In between each use,
but we do wash them.
They are machine washed
on a daily basis.
‐Ah.
‐So, Daniel...
Herjavec: ...these are
standalone places I got to.
You're not suggesting I buy
these and put them in my office.
‐Correct.
‐Okay.
We are a studio.
Oza: How much do you charge
per bed?
$9 per power nap.
‐What's a power nap?
‐So ‐‐
How long?
25 minutes.
‐Okay.
‐So if people are coming
from work, everybody's
coming at lunch, right?
So how do you handle that
the rest of the day's
pretty much
going to be empty.
Power nap is actually a hook,
but we are a more restorative
and regenerative
practices studio.
So we focus on sleep,
stress, and mindfulness.
Is it a class situation
or is it an individual
restorative situation?
So we have both guided
and non‐guided.
Why not just drive home
and take a nap?
Like, why do go to a ‐‐
‐Too far away?
‐It's too far.
‐Too far.
‐So the economics
are not making sense because
you're only asking for $75,000
for 15%.
How much have you
invested so far?
Yes, so I've invested $90,000
in the design and development
of the space as well
as additional $50,000
in operating expenses.
We were awarded a small business
loan in the amount of $158,000.
‐That's not so small!
‐In addition?
It's a pretty large
business loan.
Yeah, that's a loan.
Yeah, well, it's 6 1/4%
interest at a 60‐month term.
Corcoran: Daniel, that's on
top of the money?
I still am totally confused
as to how much money
you have in this business.
What's the total investment
in your business to date?
Total we're around $300,000.
So how many studios do you have?
What does it cost to open one?
Absolutely. So our flagship
studio is located right downtown
in the central business district
of Washington, D. C.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐We've got plenty of capacity
at our space to expa‐‐
‐What do you have right now?
‐What is the capacity?
Corcoran:
How many of these beds?
So you're looking ‐‐
you're looking between
800 to 1,000 square feet.
We've got 12 to 13 capacity.
Okay.
How much does it make?
Are you making
or losing money?
Recharj, as a studio
concept today,
actually serves as a short‐term
loss leader or break even
to serve three major purposes.
Number one, we're
leveraging the location.
That was the fanciest way
of saying "I'm losing money".
Daniel, just give me the
economics. Don't justify it.
If you ‐‐ half my
companies lose money.
We'll still sell them
for a lot.
So just give me the breakdown.
How much are we losing?
Why am I not surprised by
that, Rohan? But go ahead.
But they sell for billions.
We're going to break even by
the end of the calendar year.
We're going to make $130,000
in top‐line revenue this year.
‐Are you paid a salary?
‐I pay myself nothing.
I still have
my full‐time job.
‐You do?!
‐You do?
‐Yes.
‐Wait a minute.
Who's running Recharj?
Who's in there day to day?
I've hired
a subject matter expert
who has the sleep expertise.
She's been doing yoga meditation
in that restorative space.
Okay, well, Dan, Dan,
this is ‐‐
So you're paying her
a salary.
She managers the day
to day operation.
Are there other employees
that do the classes
and do other things?
Yeah, so we've got
about a network
of 40 outside instructors,
and they really facilitate ‐‐
‐40?
‐Well, it's a network.
They're part‐time.
They're 1099's.
‐But 40?
‐They come in, teach a class ‐‐
Well, remember,
we are not just a studio,
we also do a lot
of corporate events, as well.
So we plan on franchising
within two to three years.
Oh, Daniel, Daniel, Daniel,
you are so all over the map.
$300,000 so far to do
$130,000 a year
that'll break you even,
right?
‐Correct.
‐And that's including you
having 40 people going
basically door to door
to sell a wellness services.
Which there's a market for.
I'm not disputing that
there isn't a‐‐
They're not ‐‐
they're instructors.
They're not sellers.
Okay, well,
that's even worse, right?
They should be doing both.
Effectively, you have
only 800 square feet.
You have 12 beds,
I don't know what the hell else
you spend the money on.
It just doesn't add up,
Daniel. I'm out.
I appreciate that. Now would you
consider working with Recharj
as a wellness benefit
for your companies?
No.
[ Laughter ]
Well, he's annoyed.
Got to give him a day.
‐Like a master ‐‐
‐Always be closing!
‐I love that!
‐He might come around.
‐Daniel, I have ‐‐
‐No, let me just ‐‐
Let me just tell you where else
I see your competition.
At Landmark Theatres, we have
these incredibly comfortable
couches and we have beds.
People actually go in there
when they want a break
and they'll bring
their eye covers,
they'll bring headphones.
And they'll just kick back
and they just pass out.
There's no privacy there.
Plus ‐‐
There's no privacy here!
You got a curtain!
That's not competitive, Mark.
It's very different.
Oh, no, it's definitely
competitive.
I mean, there's a movie
going on in the background.
I disagree with Mark
that the Landmark
"Fast and the Furious 17"
lie down ‐‐
Not every movie
is "Fast and the Furious",
right?
All right, so
"Driving Miss Daisy 7".
You can go to a movie with
subtitles that you don't even
understand
and just pass out.
Yeah, Mark, nobody's
coming to your movie theater.
Let it go.
My problem is this, look,
what you've tapped into
is obviously a huge need
in this country.
We push people beyond
the limits that we push to.
And it's completely
unsustainable.
So I think philosophically
where you're going, checkmark.
‐I like it.
‐Yeah.
But it seems like
a higher investment cost
relative to what you're
making in revenue.
So for me, the juice
is not worth the squeeze.
Well, can I give you ‐‐
we're not ‐‐
So I like ‐‐
I like the idea,
but for that reason,
I'm out.
I appreciate it.
Now would you consider
working with Recharj
as a wellness benefit
for your companies?
I would be open to that!
I disagree with Rohan.
I just have
a fundamental challenge
with the entire concept.
Look, I sleep three
to four hours a day.
People say to me, "Oh, my gosh,
how can you do that?
I wish I could do that".
I don't do it by choice.
I do it because I have to.
So I would much ‐‐
Well, think how much
more successful you may be
if you did take a power nap?
I would much ‐‐
I mean, Arianna Huffington's
a huge champion for this.
I would much rather
be tired than poor.
You can be rested and rich.
Oh, come on, man.
I think most people
in America
don't have the luxury of
being able to leave their job
and go take a nap
in the middle of the day.
For that reason, I'm out.
We're seeing people do it,
but I appreciate.
And one of the things
I always say to entrepreneurs
or people that have ideas
is sometimes you just
have too many.
You're trying, like, an octopus
to tentacle out everywhere.
You can drown in
opportunity.
Yes. You have, like,
four tentacles going.
It's a good cause.
It's a healthy cause.
I like mindfulness.
I mediate.
But I think it'll be easier
for you and a better route
to take it to businesses,
sell those beds,
and get them set up.
I don't think the route
that you're going
would be a right
investment for me.
So I'm out.
‐Thank you Lori.
‐So you've got one Shark left.
‐Miss Barbara.
‐All right.
I'd love to be one of your
all stars, Barbara.
Put yourself in my spot.
Why would you give me
a couple hundred
thousand dollars
to open up another spot
only to break even?
That you claim
is a break even,
it really is never a break even
till you recoup your costs.
The model that we've built,
that we've invested in.
You spent the money on
a model that I do not
personally believe
is going to work.
And I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
I appreciate your time.
‐Good luck, Daniel.
‐Thank you.
‐Wish you the best.
‐Namaste.
This is a new concept.
And while this may have not been
the best fit for these Sharks,
I'm the eternal optimist.
And I can't wait to see what
the future has in store for us.
Maybe I'm old fashioned.
I don't want people
sleeping at work.
When people come to my office
to work, you know what ‐‐
‐Oh, I ‐‐ I don't.
‐You want to let them do it?
Well, they're doing it
at lunch.
I want them working!
Cuban: I have no problem.
You know what ‐‐
Yeah. Not always.
If I walked into
my office, Mark,
and I saw 12 of
my people sleeping,
they wouldn't be working
there much longer.
You know what,
I don't have a problem ‐‐
I have no problem if they
take a nap
as long as they're still there
at 9:00 when I'm there.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is an added
layer of protection
for some everyday items.
♪♪
‐Oh, my God!
‐Oh!
‐Ohh!
‐Nice, nice!
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
This is the worst possible
time for this to happen.
Hi, my name is David Zamarin,
and my company is Detrapel.
I'm here today seeking
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for a 20%
equity stake in my company.
You see, a coffee spill like
this could seriously
ruin a chance of making
an amazing first impression,
like I'm trying
to do right now.
And luckily for me,
I came prepared.
‐Oh, nice!
‐Now this is a super shirt ‐‐
a shirt that won't let you down
and won't let you walk
into a situation
looking like a mess.
Because this special shirt has
been treated with my product,
Detrapel.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, wow!
Detrapel is a super hydrophobic
liquid repellant spray
that is made to keep
your things clean.
Our formula shields
your belongings
from any liquid‐base
substance ‐‐
aka super hydrophobic.
Say you're watching TV
with a glass of wine.
And you accidently spill it
all over your carpet.
Watch as it beads
immediately off.
Wow.
Got to be kidding me.
Or maybe your kids step
into a mud puddle
with their brand‐new shoes.
Oh, no.
Good as new because you've got
Detrapel.
Wow!
Or say you're at a backyard
barbecue, when all of a sudden,
you get a glob of ketchup
all over your t‐shirt.
Or maybe you're someone
who likes mustard.
Corcoran:
Don't do it!
[ Laughter ]
How about some relish?
You see, no matter
what you prefer,
the shirt always stays clean
because you've got Detrapel.
‐And that's water?
‐That's water.
Now the best part is that
one easy application
lasts a whole year.
With no glossy barrier,
no white discoloration,
and it's completely non‐toxic.
Our formula is so safe
that you could even do this.
Oh, my God!
No need to worry
about carcinogens
or the need for protective gear.
Sharks, we're a young,
growing brand
that needs your help ramping
up production.
So if you want to keep
your dorsal fins clean,
then spray them with Detrapel.
How'd you come up
with the idea, David?
I grew up as a kid who comes
from very low‐income background.
My parents are both immigrants.
My dad's from Moscow,
my mom's from Kiev.
And I came up with this idea
'cause I really cared
about my stuff
because I didn't have
that much money.
Then I got these two
brand‐new Jordans
that I was so psyched about.
And I was so scared of
getting them dirty or messed up.
So I had this idea
that I want to come up
with some kind of spray
that you can put on and peel
off whenever it got dirty.
But I wasn't a chemical
engineer.
I was a freshman in high school.
So I actually pivoted my idea
and did a shoe‐cleaning business
for all the local university
sports teams in Philadelphia.
Good for you, wow!
I ran that for
about four months.
We did about $25,000
a month in revenue.
‐Cleaning shoes?
‐Cleaning shoes?!
Cleaning shoes ‐‐ basketball
shoes, cleats, you name it.
Why didn't you keep
that business going,
'cause that's easy money?
So I stopped the business
because I got an offer
to sell my first business.
And I sold it for $150,000.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Thank you, thank you.
I took almost all of it
and I put it into this.
This is all still while
you were in high school?
This all while I was
in high school.
Do you mind if I ask you
how old you are?
How old are you, David?
‐I'm 19 years old.
‐You're 19?!
‐What?!
‐No!
‐Sweet, fancy Moses!
‐You're 19?
‐You're a beast!
‐Oh, my God!
I thought you were
like 30.
So I sold the business, and I
began researching nanotech,
which is the basis
of the formula.
So luckily, I had a friend
who was a PhD from Drexel
who let me use their labs
and their microscopes.
So I went in during my summer
and I created a formula ‐‐
‐So you use nanoparticles?
‐Yes.
Right, so explain
what nanoparticles are.
Yeah, a nanoparticle
is just, literally,
if you take a regular particle
and you take it to nano size,
it's 10th to the 9th ‐‐ negative
9th degree, which means ‐‐
‐So it's a tiny particle.
‐Tiny.
‐It's so tiny.
‐Extremely tiny,
you cannot see it.
Greiner: I have a quick
question, though.
Sometimes with nanotechnology,
it's so tiny,
it can go through the skin.
Yes, so we're
a water‐based formula,
which is the main reason
why we're non‐toxic,
eco‐friendly.
It does not penetrate
the skin, then?
Your coating on your hands
and on your skin itself
has a natural wax coating
that will block anything
from going in either way,
unless you have an open sore
or an open cut.
So you create it,
you find a manufacturer...
So we had a manufacturer
that added a 1% to
2% proprietary part,
something that was crucial
to the product
that we were trying to sell.
And eight months down the line,
they went bankrupt,
and they refused to disclose
that 2% proprietary part.
So I went on, pretty much,
a three‐year hiatus
trying to re‐engineer
this formula.
But, David,
where are you now?
I'd like to hear the end
of the story.
So the original formula
is no longer what we have.
There has been a couple
slight changes.
I went into a lab and we
created this same formula.
‐It's your product.
‐Now it's 100% ours.
Your pro‐‐ And what are
your sales today?
This year, we're on track
to do $300,000 to $350,000.
And who do you sell them to?
Who's your main customer?
Now, we've really
been mainly b‐to‐b.
So you're selling to
other businesses,
what kind of businesses
are buying this?
Yeah, the businesses that are
either creating products
for consumers that they can buy,
like, furniture,
like, carpet for example.
Have you done any safety
testing on this?
We have FDA testing done.
We adhere to all the EPA
compliance regulations.
What do you charge
for it, David?
This is a sample size, but we
also sell as our travel size.
We sell this for $12.99.
And what's your cost?
To make this, $1.14.
‐Great margin.
‐You're selling this
for $12.99 where?
Directly on our website
right now.
Is it patented?
Do you have a patent
on this thing or not?
No, we haven't. Not yet.
How hard would it be
for somebody to knock it off?
I went to some of the largest
nano‐tech companies in the world
that specifically
do things like this.
None of them were able to do
what we were able to do
eventually.
See, that scares me
a little bit.
Why do I find it
too good to be true?
That's because I'm young,
but I'm telling you here
that I'm ‐‐
Age isn't the issue.
‐What's that?
‐Age isn't the issue.
If I took $200,000 and went out
and hired somebody,
could I recreate Detrapel?
No.
I believe that wholeheartedly
that you won't be able to do it.
That's simply because of
our process and on top of that,
the way that we market.
Okay, I'll shortcut this,
David.
I'll give you the $200,000,
want 25%,
and I'll put a stipulation
that you own the formula.
I'll put you in touch
with my other nano guys
who know this stuff
a whole lot better,
have all the technology,
and we can get you going.
What do you want to do?
Um...
No. Wait.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
David has one offer
on the table from Mark ‐‐
$200,000 for 25% of his
stain‐repellent Detrapel.
But Lori also seems interested.
What do you want to do?
No. Wait.
I will give you an offer
for $200,000, also for 25%.
Again, I want to make sure
that all of your testing,
all of that, shakes out.
Would you consider
partnering together?
I don't know.
What's your ultimate goal?
The ultimate goal is to extend
to an actual chemical company
that does an array
of cleaning lines ‐‐
or maybe not even cleaning,
but really protectant line.
So what is the one thing
that you think sets you apart,
that you came up with,
that is your golden ticket?
All of our products
are on a nano level.
Most companies only focus
on one thing.
By the way, I'm going
to throw in as well.
I'll give you $200,000
for 25%.
Okay, thank you all
for your offers.
So back to my question.
What expertise do you need
to get where you want to go?
I really need help on
the business side of it.
Not necessarily
on the chemical side ‐‐
I think we can figure
that part out of it.
You want brand‐building,
distribution, route to market?
That's why I'm here. I need the
right people to work with me.
All right, if that's
what you need, then,
I would go in with Lori,
right?
'Cause if it's
the business side,
we both can complement
each other.
Plus, I've got some
really strong investments
in the nano side.
Well, David, look.
Nano schmano.
I don't care.
You figure it out.
You're a 19‐year‐old
dynamo, my friend.
‐Thank you.
‐This is incredible.
I appreciate it.
I would love to be in with you.
And I would love to
have my friend Rohan
go in with me,
if he's open to it.
I was thinking $200,000
for...
23%.
Just a little sweeter,
just a little bit better
than the other Sharks.
‐Thank you.
‐Rohan?
I'm in, Robert's
highly successful,
he knows technology,
he's built stuff,
I know how to build
brands.
You know, there's big,
major companies
out there looking
for innovation like this.
They come to me to help
go find the innovation.
Robert brings a skill set
that I don't have.
Together,
it's a dynamic duo.
Mark and I have decided
that we will go in together.
I am very fast to market,
and what I do is infomercials,
TV, and retail.
‐I see that this ‐‐
‐'Cause none of us have ever
done an infomercial.
Well, I'm not going to comment
on what anybody else does.
I only know what I can do.
And I think that you
do need to move fast,
you do need to blitz
the market.
I think that Mark and I
can do that for you.
I don't think necessarily
I'm your best partner in this.
I think Lori and Mark are
an unbeatable combination
and you should grab
the money and run.
I'm out,
but go with these two.
Thank you.
Lori and I are offering you
$200,000 for 25%.
Rohan and Robert made
some crazy,
ridiculous offer
that's irrelevant,
but it turned out to be
$200,000 for 23%.
'Cause we've never built
brands on our own.
We don't know how
to make mega brands.
What would you
like to do?
All right.
David, there's something
that Rohan and I have that,
with all due respect to Lori
and Mark, they don't have.
We're immigrants to this country
and we came here with nothing.
If anybody here
understands hard work,
I think that we can help you
get to where you want to go.
‐Robert!
‐We understand that hunger.
‐Robert.
‐I like that Robert.
‐Yeah, but ‐‐
‐Time to decide, David.
♪♪
Mark and Lori,
I think you got a deal.
‐Let's do this!
‐Whoo!
Thank you, guys. I really
appreciate your offers.
‐Congratulations, David.
‐Thank you.
‐You'll be fine.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Appreciate it.
‐This is very cool.
‐Yeah, yeah.
‐Congrats, man.
‐Good job. Both of you.
‐Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
[ Both laughing ]
Lori knows all about branding,
all about products,
and we are
a product‐based business.
And Mark has the online
side covered.
He's in the nanospace.
It's just the perfect
win‐win situation.
What was the
immigrant card, Robert?
‐Obviously, I had no idea.
‐The immigrant card.
‐Talk about a Hail Mary.
‐I was with you!
I'll be the first to admit,
it was, like, bam!
♪♪